how come you always you've got beef
online you see when you get to a certain
level of success you'll see you'll see
people just start beefing for no reason
people just start coming at you why no
what is it about like what is it that
you do why people come back like that
okay I had this clip last year right
where I said okay you can leave your
girl if she gets too fat yeah and the
women didn't really like that
you can leave a man if he gets too broke
like let me do it all the time
someone done it to me last week
yeah so then they get mad because I say
like I mean I have I have five brothers
so they're allowed to have standards
just like we're allowed to have
standards and so when I talk about that
men are allowed to have standards the
women just get so mad they're like no
they can have zero standards I could be
fat and not do anything